disturbing things had been happening on
the fifth floor of the rose heights
apartment building in albany new york
residents had reported strange noises
over the last few days screaming in the
night pained muttering soft weeping
scratching and scuttling in the walls
and worst of all what seemed like an
infestation of bugs unlike anything the
unfortunate occupants of rose heights
had ever seen before they weren't
abnormal in size or shape they looked an
awful lot like the common earwig around
two and a half centimeters long with
large curved pinchers on the back but
the color wasn't right unlike the usual
dark brown these earwigs were a silverly
almost translucent gray when people
spotted them crawling across their walls
or hiding in the carpet they seemed to
shimmer in the light eventually the
building's landlady donna tompkins was
called in to do something about the
infestation she spoke to each of the
residents about their experience they
reported the strange noises the
mysterious bugs and even a funny smell
they'd sometimes catch in the hall a
smell like someone had thrown up and
every single person that donna spoke to
couldn't help but remark that the smell
was particularly strong outside the
apartment of a certain resident bill
parham stranger still was the fact that
bill hadn't been seen in days donna
knocked on his door but received no
answer she called him on his cell phone
and could hear the phone ringing inside
the apartment but it just went to
voicemail when she checked the security
footage of the lobby she saw that bill
hadn't left the building in the last few
days either donna called the police
worried that bill might be sick or even
dead inside his apartment it was strange
given that he was only in his 30s and
didn't seem to have any health
conditions but stranger things had
happened much stranger things were about
to happen too
two police officers arrived not long
after they called through the door one
more time and when they got no response
donna gave them the key to head inside
the apartment was a rack all the
furniture was covered in dust filthy
dishes were piled high in the sink and
on the draining board the smell of rot
was thick in the air there were empty
boxes of painkillers all the pills
popped from their silvery foil laying on
the ground but worst of all were the
bugs the apartment was crawling with
them and they were on every surface
those silvery gray earwigs neither of
the officers liked bugs and it seemed
like the deeper they got into the
apartment the more bugs there were some
even seemed to be crawling towards them
pointing their pinchers at them as
though they were defending their
territory this looked to be a textbook
case of what happens when a resident
keels over and dies but there was just
one problem where was the body bill
parham had seemingly dropped off the
face of the earth and now a colony of
mysterious bugs had started squatting in
his apartment in his absence then came
that smell again that truly awful smell
like bile and blood it was even stronger
now and it seemed like it was coming
from a nearby closet the two officers
acting on pure instinct drew their
weapons and approached the closet with
caution even if they weren't consciously
aware of it they knew they were going to
find something awful inside something
evil
something
dangerous when they threw open the
closet door they couldn't help but
scream they'd found the nest it was a
huge round hive like the biggest beehive
you've ever seen melded into the lower
corner of the closet the unnatural
earwigs were crawling into out of and
around it thousands of them tens of
thousands of them and the second they
registered the presence of the two
officers intruders into their nest they
began to swarm in sheer panic both
raised their guns and opened fire into
the closet but it didn't do them any
good their bullets just pierced and
splintered the hive causing even more
enraged insects to spill out and begin
crawling over the two cops they fled
from the apartment screaming in pain
from the gnashing pincers of the insects
crawling all over their skin they never
did find the corpse of bill parham but
that's because bill parham wasn't dead
at least not until mere moments ago when
the bullets from the cops's gun had torn
through his bones and perforated his
organs he died not long after and if he
could still speak close to the end he
would have thanked them both for the
mercy because the monstrosity that they
just encountered in the closet wasn't
just a nest of mysterious insects in
bill parham's apartment it was bill
himself
this is the fate worse than death in
store for anyone supremely unlucky
enough to fall victim to scp-439
better known by the nickname for their
unique nests the bone hive and while
these nasty little critters may be small
they're filled with enough pure
nightmare fuel to send you running into
682's containment chamber for a little
comfort let's go through this whole
nightmarish process and tell you exactly
what happened to poor bill parham first
discovered by the scp foundation in
mainland china
scp-439 specimens largely get by on the
fact that they're not much to look at
unless you're an entomologist when you
see a strange insect you probably just
accept the fact that it's a perfectly
normal breed you've just never
encountered before nobody is hammering
down the doors of their local news
station to alert the press about the
grey earwig they saw crawling out of a
crack in their bathroom wall but if bill
parham had done just that it would have
saved his life
the foundation would have immediately
flagged the incident as an scp-439
infestation and dispatched a mobile task
force to deal with it instead when bill
saw the earwig for the first time he was
getting ready for work and didn't have
the time to stop and deal with it he
made a mental note to buy some bug
killer on the way home but quickly
forgot the insect didn't forget him
though in fact it thought he would be a
perfect candidate for the scp-439
process the foundation has tested
extensively with the one scp-439 sample
they'd been able to successfully catch
and contain in all tests they found that
439 specimens rejected hosts from any
species other than humans they're an
extraordinarily specific parasite it's
also only one particular type of scp-439
specimen that you actually need to worry
about the queens despite their
superficial similarities scp-430 behave
nothing like non-anomalous earwigs
normal earwigs are not social creatures
they're solitary scavengers and they
don't keep nests as permanent habitats
the same can definitely not be said for
scp-439
they have complex social structures much
like that of bees ants and termites with
queens scouts workers and warriors if
you happen to encounter a worker or a
warrior you may get a painful pinch from
their pinchers if you get too close but
if you end up on the wrong side of one
of the queens then you have a much much
worse fate in store for you and it just
so happened that the scp-439 specimen
that appeared in bill parham's bathroom
that morning was visiting royalty this
439 queen had selected her target and
now it was time to move to the next part
of the process
initial infiltration when bill returned
home from work he was delighted to find
that the gray earwig was nowhere to be
seen but that didn't mean it was gone it
was still there lurking it just didn't
want to be seen after all the real fun
would happen after bill went to bed once
scp-439 detects that its potential host
has fallen into a deep sleep it will
crawl onto the person's body and into
their mouth which is exactly what it did
to bill it feels like little more than a
tickle in your throat and you will have
no idea that the tiny creature crawling
down your windpipe and into the soft
warm tissue of your lungs spells your
doom very few people wake up during this
process but even if they did there's
virtually nothing they could do when
bill woke up he was suffering from mild
chest pains and shortness of breath a
symptom not uncommon in a number of
respiratory ailments he had no idea that
the scp-439 queen was already inside him
he got up and went about his day trying
to ignore the pain as it gradually grew
worse and worse feeling almost like
something was moving inside his chest he
spent the whole day having to stop to
let out a deep hacking cough but
coughing didn't expel or change anything
he looked and felt so terrible that his
boss let him go home early hoping that
bill would be able to sleep off whatever
illness he thought he had picked up but
over the next couple of days
his condition only worsened the pain
grew so excruciating he could barely
move and he was popping painkillers like
tic tacs to no effect he started running
a dangerously high fever his body trying
in vain to fight back against its lethal
intruder he felt worse than he ever had
in his life but little did poor bill
know the most terrible parts of the
process were yet to come through
anomalous means an scp-439 infection is
able to induce fibrodysplasia ossoficans
progressiva or fop in its victims which
is typically a genetic disease that
presents itself before the victim turns
10 years old the condition is infamous
for its primary symptom turning muscle
and other soft tissue into bone slowly
but surely paralyzing the victim and
putting them into a state of unspeakable
pain
this bone transformation process is
known as ossification and bill was about
to experience it firsthand his pain
increased as his mobility decreased with
more of his flesh becoming solid lumps
of bone underneath the skin soon enough
all he knew was pain it'd become so
agonizing that he was delirious with it
he was drunk on pain even perceiving
sunlight felt like being stabbed in the
eyes that's why like all the other
victims of scp-439
he decided to conceal himself in a warm
dark place where no light could get to
him in bill's case of course that place
was his closet he was hurting so bad
that all he could do was curl up into
the fetal position and weep as his
muscles turned to bone and his body
began to compact and shrink he didn't
even look like a human anymore he was
more like a ball covered in a bone shell
and filled with warm organs that's when
the queen started laying eggs among his
organs it wasn't long before there was a
new brood of around 30 000 specimens
living inside bill's body he was still
very much alive but there wasn't
anything he could do about his situation
his muscles had long since turned to
bone and they had eaten large portions
of his brain leaving mainly the parts
needed to keep his organs just barely
functioning after all the colony still
needs central heating
scp-439 colonies have developed a
perfect parasitic relationship with the
human body they even use the stomach
inside the hive to pre-digest food into
a liquid slurry that's easier for them
to consume the only loser in this
situation is someone like bill who is
forced to become the new home for the
world's most nightmarish freeloaders
eventually when the colony becomes too
big a queen departs to start a new one
and the process repeats itself once more
it's enough to make you want to sleep
with your mouth closed for the rest of
your life oh and we haven't even told
you the worst part yet foundation
scientists have conducted tests on some
victims of scp-439
and found that while the creatures do
consume large parts of the brain the
parts they leave are capable of
consciousness
that's right their victims remain aware
of what's happening to them the whole
time even when they hardly seem human at
all anymore what actually finally kills
the victims of scp-439 isn't the bodily
trauma it's the starvation that sets in
when the colony inevitably moves on did
we just hear you cough you might want to
go get that checked out now go watch
scp-001 when day breaks and
scp-823 carnival of horrors for more
terrifying scps that'll chill you to the
bone